hey Vsauce Michael here Gregory W Nimitz
registered some land containing 492
quintillion dollars worth of platinum
the land was right here well over here
an asteroid named 433 eros not a single
sovereign nation on earth recognizes
human claims to extraterrestrial real
estate but he did it anyway and then
less than a year later NASA landed a
probe on the asteroid they called it the
first asteroid we had ever landed a
probe on Nimitz called it parking space
number 29 and promptly sent NASA a $20
parking ticket
but so far NASA and the US Attorney
General have dismissed the fine saying
that his claim to own the asteroid is
without legal merit but why plenty of
organizations exist that will gladly
take your money in return for land on
the moon Venus Mars and if you had
enough money to go to the moon nothing
is legally stopping you from moving
there building a house with a
significant other having some kids and
turning your moon house into a moon home
it wouldn't be trespassing or squatting
or stealing the 1979 moon treaty says
that no one can own any part of outer
space ever but only 11 states have
signed it however 129 nations have
signed and/or ratified the 1967 Outer
Space Treaty which says that outer space
is not subject to national appropriation
it says nothing about a private
individual or a company owning part of
outer space but without the recognition
and support of at least one sovereign
nation what does ownership
really mean I mean I can claim any
want I can claim to own Prospect Park in
Brooklyn but just saying that I do or
even moving there and living in Prospect
Park wouldn't entitle me to the rights
that usually go along with ownership
unless someone with a bunch of power
agreed that I owned it and could enforce
that ownership and keep others from
claiming to also own it in the past
explorers had few qualms about claiming
to own land even if other humans were
already there because they had power on
their side mainly plenty of Guns Germs
and Steel
to paraphrase con artists Canada Bill
Jones you know what beats for aces a gun
or as la blob pointed out McDonald's
actually does serve breakfast after
10:30 if you have a gun if you claimed
some land on the moon as your own and
moved in would you also have to hire
your own lunar police and cislunar
military to defend it and to keep others
from challenging your claim pretty much
that's kind of the problem currently it
is risky for individuals or corporations
to claim and use extraterrestrial
territory because the Outer Space Treaty
says that outer space is the common
heritage of mankind it belongs to all of
us and only to all of us many
interpretations of the Outer Space
Treaty predict that powerful things like
nations would be reluctant to come to
your defense
should someone else want to move in or
cause trouble or dispute your
extraterrestrial claim
maybe you could get a sovereign nation
to weigh in on your behalf by declaring
universal jurisdiction but that would
need to be for an incredibly terrible
heinous crime a crime against all of
humanity not just a dispute over a few
space rocks catherine dole dureena from
the institute of air and space law at
mcgill university suggests that
considering outer space the common
heritage of mankind has slowed space
exploration you see the outer space
treaty was based on the Antarctic Treaty
which says that the entire continent
shall never become the scene or object
of international discord discord is not
a good thing but without an incentive to
profit from it not much has happened
there as opposed to the Arctic where a
resource boom is currently underway if
people felt safer appropriating and
taking advantage of space of celestial
bodies
if technological development was more
incentivized would we already have
orbiting tourist attractions and lunar
hotels maybe but here is what you can
currently own in outer space stuff you
put there and to a certain extent orbits
the Outer Space Treaty says that the
stuff we left on the moon anything put
into space remains property of the
original owner forever orbits around
Earth are temporarily granted by the
International Telecommunication Union a
UN agency but they don't work like
typical real estate on earth when a
group of equatorial nations attempted to
claim orbits above their land boundaries
without planning on putting satellites
there their claim was largely ignored so
you not only need to ask the UN for an
orbit and get permission you also need
to use it and fill it it's a little
disappointing that we don't know how
lunar real-estate work
or if it will but it's exciting to know
that we within our lifetimes might have
a chance to be part of the solution a
unique generation not visiting space for
the first time but homesteading it for
the first time
here's another unresolved space law
quandary if an alien landed in your
backyard intelligent life from beyond
Earth and you shot it with a gun dressed
it and then cooked up you and your
family some alien meat fajitas would
that be hunting or murder we literally
don't know on earth we have human rights
but there are no alien rights maybe it
would fall under the category of
cultural vandalism an act that's not
necessarily illegal but is a giant
bummer to the rest of humanity this has
happened before
not with aliens but with paintings in
2003 the Chapman brothers purchased one
of the few remaining sets of Goya's
fantastic disasters of war instead of
displaying the works for the public they
defaced them by drawing clown and puppy
heads on the people they called the work
insult to injury in protests a man threw
red paint on Jake Chapman when he
appeared at Modern Art Oxford but at the
end of the day what the Chapman brothers
did wasn't illegal they owned the
paintings vandalizing the moon or
killing a peaceful alien aren't illegal
acts but just like defacing historical
paintings they seem wrong on some deeper
level especially since because in most
museums you usually can't even touch the
paintings but who was the first person
to touch the moon with their bare hands
I mean the guys who walked around on the
moon wore spacesuits they had material
in between their skin and the moon well
to be sure you already have the moon in
your hands
well little moons lenola the crescent
shaped area at the base of your
fingernail where tissue is thicker and
the red vascular structures underneath
are more hidden making it white and to
be even more sure at the quantum level
touch is problematic as I've covered
before atomically speaking mater never
really contacts other matter in the
conventional sense you can't truly touch
anything minutephysics called it
interaction over a short distance
with that in mind nASA says that Terri
Slezak was the first person to touch the
moon with his bare hands he was a
technician in quarantine who
accidentally got lunar soil smeared all
over his hand while removing film
magazines from the astronauts cameras
but when Armstrong and Aldrin returned
to the lunar module after their moonwalk
and removed their helmets they came into
contact with lunar dust they tracked in
on their suits they even reported its
odor saying it smelled of spent
gunpowder or ashes possibly because it
oxidized on contact with the air in the
cabin point is the first few breaths of
Moon dusty air that Armstrong and Aldrin
took in were our first fleshly contact
with the moon or were they walking
around on earth every day I am
surrounded by material that recently was
in outer space
hundreds of metric tons of
extraterrestrial rock falls to earth
every year some from the moon but most
from asteroids ejected by a high-speed
impact and eventually caught by Earth's
gravity some pieces are big enough to
see but most are pulverized by our
atmosphere during entry into tiny
particles that disperse in
the air becoming a tiny fraction of the
very dust and dirt we clean up and
breathe in every day there's microscopic
space dust pieces of asteroids and even
the moon all around us in fact there
might be microscopic pieces of the moon
under your bed right now or even under
your fingernails which means the first
human to have fleshly contact with lunar
material was the first Homo Sapien
hundreds of thousands of years ago to
walk on dirt we are still studying
exactly how much cosmic dust is in the
air that we breathe every day but it's
safe to say that every once in a while
you inhale some material that was
recently in outer space some of which
thousands of years ago was on the moon
was the moon and just like other
particulates in our atmosphere large
enough pieces get trapped in the mucus
that protects our lungs meaning that
picking your nose
is gross but every once in a while a
booger could literally be out of this
world and as always thanks for watching
[Music]